this program is brought to you by Emory
University
ix nitric oxide really is a very
important gas that's produced by cells
throughout the body it's really
important for blood pressure regulation
for protection of the heart protection
of organs in general across the body and
the issue is that nitric oxide has a
very short half-life it only remains in
the body for a few seconds it's a free
radical species and it's rapidly broken
down and so one of the problems in
translation to the clinic has been how
to deliver nitric oxide therapies over a
long term or more chronic basis in
recent years we've discovered and others
that nitric oxide dude it's short
half-life is actually rapidly broken
down into a molecule called nitrite and
nitrite appears to be a very stable
storage molecule that can be converted
back into nitric oxide during conditions
of hypoxia or ischemia such as might
happen during a heart attack or a stroke
and now scientists are really
investigating how we can harness the the
use of nitrite to deliver nitric oxide
during cardiovascular diseases and a
number of other diseases and of interest
is the idea that green leafy vegetables
that have been thought to be healthy for
many years actually contain contain
levels of nitrite and nitrate and
nitrate can be converted back into
nitrite and then into nitric oxide so
now we have a way that we can modify our
diet in a healthy manner it's also
interesting to note that people that
have diseases cardiovascular diseases
and other diseases have very low levels
of nitrite and nitrate in their bodies
and so this begs the question could we
improve their health by increasing the
amount of nitrite and nitrate in their
diet nitric oxide is has a very short
half-life in the body and many of its
very powerful protective effects are
difficult to harness with nitric oxide
based drugs however scientists
discovered that nitric oxide is actually
broken down into nitrite and nitrite is
incredibly stable in the body it sticks
around for a long period of time however
when the
he suffers low blood flow or hypoxia or
some disease state nitrite is rapidly
converted directly into nitric oxide or
enno as it's called and this enno can
then exert beneficial effects dilate
blood vessels improve blood flow and
alleviate the low blood flow or the
hypoxic condition and this could be
life-saving so research has been
initiated and a number of diseases both
cardiovascular and non cardiovascular
disease states to study the use of
nitrite given orally or by injection to
protect
so since nitrite has emerged is a very
very important method to increase whole
body nitric oxide levels a number of
scientists in England in Germany and in
the u.s. as well as other other
universities all over the world have
been trying to harness this molecule in
a number of ways and clearly there are
diseases that are very acute in nature
such as a stroke or a heart attack in
which scientists are looking to perform
clinical trials to give injected
versions of sodium nitrite and this
nitrite can then be converted to enno
and protect the brain or the heart
against these very harmful situations
but for more chronic diseases such as
high blood pressure or hypertension
peripheral arterial disease and also
pulmonary hypertension it's clear that
that scientists and pharmaceutical
companies are looking at utilizing oral
forms of sodium nitrite that can be
taken every day to increase whole body
levels of nitrite and then increase the
amount of enno and alleviate these very
harmful situations that protect the
patient against these these
cardiovascular disease states
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University